[موسيقى]
مساء الخير قد تكون منطقه الشرق الاوسط
على اعتاب تطور اخر جديد درامي مهم وهو
عوده العلاقات المصريه الايرانيه خلال
الاسابيع القليله المقبله اقول قبل ان
هناك مفاوضات جاده تجري بين البلدين منذ
شهور
بوساطه عمانيه عراقيه
والسؤال اللي بيطرح نفسه لماذا انقطعت
العلاقات بين مصر وايران في المقام الاول
ولماذا قد تعود الان لكن استاذنكم قبل ان
نحاول الاجابه على هذا السؤال
نوضح ان العلاقات بين مصر وايران تكنيك
ليست مقطوعه ولكنها عند ادنى مستوياتها
مكاتب تمثيل دبلوماسي ولما تكون العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه عند ادنى مستوياتها يعني ان
العلاقات متدهوره او لا توجد علاقات اصلا
يعني لا توجد علاقات تجاريه ولا سياسيه
ولا عسكريه ولا ثقافيه لا توجد رحلات مثلا
يوميه بين البلدين وهكذا نعود الى اجابه
السؤال لماذا انقطعت العلاقات بالمصري
قصه طويله ولكن نقدر نلخصها في انه
التدهور العلاقات بين مصر وايران كان واحد
من النتائج السريعه لقيام الثوره
الايرانيه عام
1979 الثوره ديت ادت الى تدهور العلاقات
بين ايران وبين كثير من دول العالم ومنها
مصر قبل
1979 كانت العلاقات الايرانيه المصريه
بتتارجح ما بين القوه والفتور يعني مثلا
اثناء الحكم الملكي شهدت بعض سنوات هذه
الفتره علاقات قويه جدا وكانت افضل في
افضل مراحلها عندما قرر شاه ايران محمد
رضا بهلوي الزواج من اخت الملك فاروق
الاميره فوزيه عام 1939
وطبعا هذا الزواج انتهى لاحقا بالطلاق في
عام 1945
ثم مرحله من الفطور في معظم فترات حكم
الرئيس جمال عبد الناصر لاسباب كثيره جدا
وبالمناسبه رئيس جمال عبد الناصر كانت
زوجته السيده تحيه من اصل ايراني وكان
احيانا يقول مازحا للايرانيين الايرانيين
تعبيني في البيت وبره البيت
ثم فتره من العلاقات القويه بين مصر
وايران اثناء حكم الرئيس الراحل محمد انور
السادات لكن جاءت الثوره الاسلاميه سنه 79
وعمقت الخلافات
والتناقضات بين البلدين لفتره طويله جدا
حوالي 45 سنه ايه اسباب الخلافات
والتناقضات اللي ظهرت مع الثوره الاسلاميه
سنه 79 كثيره لكن ابرزها واحد توقيع مصر
اتفاقيه السلام مع
اسرائيل سنه 79 بالنسبه للثوره الاسلاميه
والقياده الجديده ايرانو اسرائيل عدو فاذا
قررت مصر التطبيع مع اسرائيل واصبحت في
المعسكر اللي بتقوده الولايات المتحده
اللي هي الشيطان الاكبر بالنسبه للثوره
الاسلاميه فهذا سبب كافي لتوطير العلاقات
مع السلطات الايرانيه
اضف الى ذلك استضافه الرئيس المصري السابق
السادات لشهر ايران كلاجئ سياسي في مارس
وللتوضيح شاه ايران
فره بعد اندلاع الثوره اظن في 16 يناير
وظل يبحث لنفسه عن بلد تقبله كلاجئ فلم
يجد الا مصر التي اصرت على استقباله اللي
هو الرئيس السادات يعني رغم معارضه بعض
القوى في مصر على اعتبار ان هذه الخطوه
سوف تستفز الايرانيين دون سبب وجيه
لكنه اصر على استقباله وحين توفي شهر
ايران دفن في مسجد الرفاعي اللي هو المسجد
الشهير في القاهره القديمه وطبعا ردت
ايران على هذه الخطوه باطلاق اسم الضابط
الذي اغتال السداد في اكتوبر 81 اللي هو
خالد الاسلامبولي على احد شوارع طيران في
وقت لاحق وبالمناسبه اطلاق اسم خالد على
احد شوارع طهران ظل واحد من القضايا
الخلافيه بين مصر وايران
مصر بتطالب بايه حذف هذا الاسم وايران
بتتمسك باطلاق اسمه على هذا الشارع تخليدا
لذكراه
السبب الثالث اللي وتر العلاقه بين مصر
وايران كان الدعم المصري للعراق في حربه
على ايران من سنه 80 الى سنه
كل هذه الاعتبارات بتبدو جزءا من تاريخ اه
صحيح تاريخ حديث جدا ولكنها فتره تقريبا
انتهت قد يبدو هذا صحيحا لكن ظلت هذه
الاعتبارات بتعكر العلاقات بين البلدين
واضيف اليها اسباب اخرى كثيره في السنوات
الاخيره
اول هذه الاعتبارات اللي ادت الى مزيد من
توتير العلاقات كان ايواء ايران لعناصر
مطلوبه من جانب اجهزه الامن المصري
القضيه ديت كما علمت يعني من بعض المصادر
المطلعه على يعني
طبيعه العلاقات المصريه الايرانيه بتحظى
باهتمام اكبر مما يعني كنت اتخيله في ملف
العلاقات المصريه الايرانيه لسببين السبب
الاول انه المسؤولين الامنيين
اعتبروا ان هذه العناصر اللي بيعتقدوا ان
ايران تاويها هي مصدر خطر على الامن
القومي المصري عناصر متطرفه عناصر من وجهه
نظر المصريين يجب ان يكون مكانها السجن
وليس يعني لجوءا في دوله المفروض ان هي
بتقول عاوزه تكون دوله صديقه لكن الامر
الثاني اللي بيثير شقوق المصريين هو
علامات الاستفهام على الاسباب اللي بتدفع
ايران الى ايواءهم
وانكارها انها تاويهم
هل تاويينهم مثلا للاستعانه بهم في وقت
الحاجه لا بقت نظر المصريه بقت النظر
الايرانيه انها بتتمسك بانهم ليسوا
موجودين
الى اخره السبب الثاني هو الوجود الايراني
الثقيل الغير مرغوب فيه
في قطاع غزه ونفس الشيء بالنسبه لليمن من
خلال دعمهم للحوثيين وقبل دعمهم للحوثيين
دعمهم او وجودهم في السودان من خلال حكم
الرئيس عمر حسن البشير رئيس السوداني
السابق الامر الذي يهدد الامن القومي
المصري سواء بوجودهم في غزه
او بتهديد باب المندب وبالتالي الملاحه
البحريه في البحر الاحمر وبالتالي قناه
السويس ثم بعد ذلك في ايضا في السنوات
الاخيره العلاقات القويه بين ايران ورئيس
وزراء اثيوبيا ابي احمد اللي هو على خلاف
حاد مع المصريين على عدد من القضايا اهمها
طبعا سد النهضه اضف الى كل هذه الاعتبارات
العلاقات
الايرانيه الخليجيه التي ظلت متوتره
لسنوات طويله على الاقل اربع دول الخليجيه
ظلت لسنوات طويله بتعتبر ايران خطا مصدر
الخطر الاساسي على انها القومي السعوديه
الامارات البحرين الكويت وبالتالي باعتبار
ان هذه الدول دول حليفه وصديقه لمصر كانت
مصر ايضا تراعي هذا البعد
في علاقتها مع ايران او في عدم اقامه
علاقات مع ايران
ثم ان الايرانيين وده سبب سادس ازعجه
السلطات المصريه ايضا في السنوات الاخيره
بحماسهم لانشاء طريق بل اكثر من طريق
كبديل لقناه السويس لربط الشرق بالغرب ودي
قضيه تحدثنا عنها قبل ذلك في حلقه تتعلق
بالطرق البديده لقناه السويس استاذنكم ان
تعودوا اليها حتى لا نكرر ما جاء فيها
ولكنها كانت مصدر ازعاج للمصريين يمكن ان
تضيف الى كل هذه الاسباب طبعا انه الفيتو
الغربي الغرب بيضغط على كل دول العالم الا
تطبع مع ايران وهذه الضغوط تمثل صداعا
لمصر ولاي دوله تفكر في التفاوض مع ايران
صداعا لا ضروره له بالنسبه للمصريين اذا
اخذنا في الاعتبار كل هذه الاسباب السابقه
لتوتير العلاقه بين البلدين للتوضيح اكثر
وعشان ما يكونش كلامنا انشائي اعطيكم مثل
او اتنين بالتفصيل اكتر لما اجي اقول مثلا
انه
الوجود الايراني ثقيل في غزه ده معناه ايه
معناها انه في تعارض كبير في المصالح بين
البلدين فيما يتعلق بقطاع غزه
مثلا مصر بترغب في رؤيه قطار غزه منطقه
هادئه مستقره بعيده عن النفوذ الاجنبي عن
الشبكات الارهابيه خصوصا الشبكات
الارهابيه المرتبطه
بالعناصر الارهابيه في سيناء اللي بتشكل
تهديد للامن القومي المصري لكن ايران
بتعتبر غزه قاعده اخرى تستطيع من خلالها
تحديد اسرائيل ولعب بدور اكبر في ملفات
المنطقه المختلفه يعني ايه لعب اكبر في
ملفات المنطقه المختلفه تخيل معايا كده
انه لما يكون له
في لبنان عن طريق حزب الله لما يكون لها
نفوذ في غزه عن طريق حركه الجهاد بشكل خاص
والجماعات الاخرى ومنها حماس بالدرجه
الثانيه لما يكون لها نفوذ كبير في اليمن
عن طريق الحوثيين لما يكون لها نفوذ كبير
في سوريا في العراق معناها ان اي دوله في
العالم اذا ارادت ان تحافظ على مصالحها في
هذه الدول عليها ان تطرق باب طهران اولا
ولما تذهب الى طهران او الايرانيين ابتدوا
يقايدوا كيف اذا اردت ان تحمي مصالحك في
هذه الدول عليك ان تراعي مصالحنا ايضا
للتوضيح اكثر واكثر مصر ليست مهتمه بقطاع
غزه لاسباب انسانيه ولكن لاسباب تتعلق
بامنها القومي
قطاع غزه تحدي كبير جدا تحدي كبير لاي
دوله
بالمناسبه التحدي الكبير لدرجه انه
اسرائيل اللي يعني ترغب في ان تحتل اكبر
مساحه ممكنه من كل الاراضي قررت ان تتخلص
من هذا التحدي لانها غير قادره عليه في
2005 وخرجت منه بدون تنسيق مع السلطات
الفلسطينيه وتركته
السادات قبلها في مفاوضات السلام من 78
لتسعه وسبعين رفض فكره عوده السياده
المصريه على قطاع غزه كما كان الحال قبل
عام
1967 ليه لان قطاع غزه
واحد من اكثر مناطق العالم اقتضادم
بالسكان بالنسبه لمساحته الصغيره جدا عدد
سكان غزه بنهايه 22 وفقا للارقام
الفلسطينيه الرسميه حوالي اتنين واربعه من
عشره مليون يعني يقترب من اتنين ونص مليون
نسمه معدل الزياده لا تقل عن 50 الف نسمه
سنويا معدلات الفقر عاليه جدا في هذا
القطاع اللي هو فقير في موارده الطبيعيه
وطبعا بيزداد فقره بسبب الحصار الاسرائيلي
في هذه المساحه الضيقه الاتنين واربعه من
عشره مليون نسمه دول بيمثلوا شعب حي يريد
الحياه ولا يجد سبيلا لها وبالتالي هم
عايشين في سجن كبير ما يعني انه
احتمال الانفجار وارد في كل لحظه
اضف الى ذلك انه ما بين الاتنين واربعه من
عشره مليون نسمه زي اي شعب هناك عناصر
عندها افكار متطرفه جهاديه وغير جهاديه من
يحكم غزه اصلا من وجهه النظر المصريه هي
حركه حماس وحركه حماس بالنسبه للمصريين او
بالنسبه للسلطات المصريه هي امتداد لجماعه
الاخوان المسلمين اللي بتعتبرها الحكومه
المصريه جماعه ارهابيه
وهي بتحكم بتتغذى اللي هو موجود فين اللي
هو طبعا موجود على
يعني الحدود حدود سيناء بشكل مباشر وسيناء
وما ادراك ما سينادي ثقب اسود في الامن
القومي المصري معنى كده ان كل ما يحدث في
غزه يؤثر بشكل مباشر في قطاع في في سيناء
يؤثر على الامن القومي المصري اي اشتباكات
مع الجانب الاسرائيلي هتنعكس على المصريين
اي ارتباط ما بين الجامعات المتطرفه في
غزه والجامعات المتطرفه في سيناء هتنعكس
سلبا على المصريين اي عمليه عبور لتجاره
غير مشروعه او
ارهاب او سلاح او غيره عبر سيناء عبر غزه
يؤثر مباشره على مصر وطبعا كلنا تابعنا
مؤخرا
الحادثه الاخيره اللي وفقا للروايه
الرسميه
عسكري مصري قتل ثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين
وهو يطارد بعض العناصر الاجراميه وده كان
ممكن ان يؤدي الى اشتعال العلاقه بين مصر
يعني واسرائيل السبب ايضا الى المنطقه
كلها منطقه ملتهبه واي شيء يحدث فيها
هيؤثر بشكل مباشر على الامن القومي المصري
طيب انا بقول كل القصه دي ليه عشان اقول
انه مصر اخر ما تحتاجه ان تستخدم ايران
غزه
يعني كورق الضغط على اسرائيل وتحرك
حلفائها هناك خاصه حركه الجهاد وفقا
لاولوياتها دون مراعاه الاولويات المصريه
اللي هي طوال الوقت طبعا لا تتفق او
تتناقض مع الاولويات الايرانيه يعني تبقى
مصر عاوزه تهدئ وايران عاوزه تصاعد مثلا
فدي مساله خطيره بالنسبه للمصريين
اضف الى كل ماذا خذ عندك المثل اللي في
اليمن اخر ما تتمناه مصر انه ايران تدعم
جماعات
غير حليفه لمصر او على علاقه متوتره مع
مصر وعلاقه متوتره مع حلفاء في الخليج
وتسيطر من خلال هذه الجامعات زي الجامعات
الحوثيه مثلا على مضيق باب المندب
وبالتالي تستطيع ان تهدد التجاره في هذا
المضيق الحيوي جدا اللي هو مدخل البحر
الاحمر وبالتالي مدخل قناه السويس اللي
بتمثل اولويه قصوى للاقتصاد والامن القومي
المصري
بالنسبه لاثيوبيا المساله ايضا بالغت
الاهميه مصر تراقب باهتمام اي دوله بتوثق
علاقتها مع رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي ابي
احمد او النخب الاثيوبيه اللي على خلاف مع
الدوله المصريه سواء على القضيه الاساسيه
اللي هي سد النهضه او اي قضايا اخرى
في تقدير انه ايران مش بتوثق علاقتها بابي
احمد يعني نكايه في مصر هي بتوثق علاقتها
مع ابي احمد لانها تريد ان توثق علاقتها
مع كل الدول الافريقيه كل القوى الاقليميه
ايران تركيا
اسرائيل دول الخليج
الدول الهند اندونيسيا الدول الاوروبيه
حتى اللي هي متوسطه زي اسبانيا الدول
الكبيره روسيا الصين الولايات المتحده كله
بيبحث عن موطئ قدم له في افريقيا على
اعتبار انه افريقيا
يعني هي كنز للثروات الطبيعيه ثم انها
اسواق ضخمه جدا من حيث عدد السكان
اسباب كثيره تحدثنا عنها في حلقه سابقه
استاذنكم ان تعودوا اليها وبالتالي ايران
تتمنى ان توثق علاقتها باثيوبيا وبغير
اثيوبيا ولكن اثيوبيا بتمثل اهتمام خاص
للايرانيين واحد لما يكون عندها علاقات
مميزه مع دوله كانت وما زالت حليفا
تقليديه للولايات المتحده واسرائيل ده
بيعطي ايران ورقه ضغط على الاسرائيليين
والولايات المتحده يعني جزء من صراعها مع
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل بتحاول ان
تسلبهم حليفا تقليديا لهم
اثنين انه ايران حريصه ان تكون موجوده
بالقرب من منطقه او في القلب من منطقه
القرن الافريقي علشان تكون قادره على
التاثير فيما يجري في هذه المنطقه الحيويه
اللي هي ملاصقه للبحر الاحمر بالمندب
الجزيره العربيه كانت متواجده
مستقره يعني او بتتمتع بنفوذ لسنوات اثناء
حكم عن عمر حسن البشير وايضا كانت بتتمتع
بنفوز مميز لبعض الوقت في ريتريا لكن
تراجع هذا النفوذ في السودان بعد سقوط عمر
حسن البشير في ابريل 2019 تراجع نفوذها في
اريتريا نتيجه ضغط الدول الخليجيه ومصر
فبحثت عن بديل ووجدت هذا البديل في ابي
احمد
اضف الى كل ده طبعا انه وجودها في اثيوبيا
اللي هي واحده من اكبر البلدان الافريقيه
من حيث عدد السكان والمساحه ويعطيها يعني
فرصه ان هي توثق علاقتها بباقي الدول
افريقيا
المجاوره لاثيوبيا على كل الاحوال هذه
العلاقات اللي هي علاقات تجاوزت العلاقات
التقليديه واصبحت تمد ابي احمد بيه
الاسلحه اللي استخدمها في صراعه مثلا ضد
التجراي امرا اثار قلق المصريين كثيرا كل
نقطه زي ما قلت لحضراتكم شرحتها لها
تفاصيل كثيره ولكن هذا امر يطول شرحه في
النهايه الخلاصه ان هناك تعارض
وتناقضات واضحه بين الاولويات المصريه
والاولويات الايرانيه في الوقت الحالي
المساله مش بس يعني خلافات تاريخيه على كل
الاحوال يبدو ان مصر وايران رغم كل هذه
الخلافات والتناقضات بيدخلاني فصلا جديدا
في علاقتهما
المفاوضات اللي بتجري بين مصر وايران
اللي كشف عنه بدايه من فبراير الماضي
فبراير 2023 وربما جرت قبل ذلك بالمناسبه
كانت في محاولات على مدار السنوات الماضيه
كثيره لاعاده العلاقات لكنها فشلت بسبب كل
هذه التناقضات اللي انا اشرت اليها ربما
وعلى الارجح قد تكتب قد يكتب النجاح
للمفاوضات اللي بتجري الان به البلدين هي
اكثر جديه من محاولات سابقه في السنوات
الماضيه ما الذي جد اللي جد في تقديري هو
رغبه ايرانيه بيقودها او بيباركها المرشد
علي خمينائي اللي هو قائد الثوره
الاسلاميه بشكل علني وقال هو في يعني منذ
ايام قليله لما قابل السلطان سلطان هيثم
سلطان
عمان انه يرغب ويؤيد عوده العلاقات معاه
المصريين
رغبه المرشد رغبه القيادات الايرانيه عامه
في عوده العلاقات مع مصر هي جزء من توجه
ايراني تبلور في الشهور الاخيره
خلاصته الرغبه الايرانيه في تلطيف الاجواء
مع دول الجوار
سببه في تقديري واحنا اتكلمنا عنه في
حلقات سابقه انه محاوله ايرانيه لاجهاض اي
ضرب عسكريه او مزيد من الضغوط الامريكيه
الاسرائيليه عليها مع تعثر الاتفاق النووي
حتى هذه اللحظه ازاي تلطيف الاجواء مع مصر
والدول العربيه
يجهض اي محاوله امريكيه او اسرائيليه
للعدوان على ايران ببساطه ما انا لما يكون
على علاقه طيبه بدول الخليج مع مصر مع
المغرب مع الاردن لن تكون هناك
سبب او عذر للولايات المتحده تبرر به
عدوانها على ايران لن تجد الولايات
المتحده واسرائيل التعاون المطلوب لتوجيه
ضربه الى ايران
ده من الجانب الايراني من الجانب المصري
بقى في اعتبارات اخرى واحد ان هناك مناخ
استرخاء عام في المنطقه يعني ديطانت ايه
اللي اتكلمنا عنه قبل كده المنطقه كانت في
حاله اشتباك منذ
اندلاع ثورات الربيع العربي في 2011 وظلت
عمليه الاشتباك الكل مشتبك مع الكل حتى
عام تقريبا نهايه
2020 ثم مع نهايه 2020 وبدايه 2021 بدات
المنطقه تتجه الى عمليه ديطانت او تحسين
للعلاقات فيما بينها تعرضنا لهذه القضيه
كثيرا في حلقات سابقه سوف اضع لكم روابطها
لتعودوا اليها ولا نكرر ما جاء فيها انما
خلاصتها كده ان دول المنطقه اولا ادركت
انه كل وسائل المواجهه الخشنه جربت ولم
تنفع فعليها ان تجرب وسيله اخرى وهي
محاوله حل خلافاتها بالطرق الدبلوماس ايه
اللي خلى الدول تكتشف هذا فجاه يعني بدايه
من 2021 ببساطه التغير في التغيرات اللي
بتاجر على الساحه الدوليه الولايات
المتحده لم تعد شريكا موثوقا فيه من كل
دول المنطقه وتركت المنطقه كده
لشانها مادام الولايات المتحده تركت دول
المنطقه لشانها دول المنطقه اللي جربت
الوسائل الخشنه قررت ان هي او ادركت ان
الوسائل الخشنه ان الصراع بشكل مباشر او
بالوكاله لم يحقق ابدا على الاقل في حاله
ايران ان يحقق اي نتائج وبالتالي وجدوا
انه لماذا لا نجرب العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
ربما تؤدي الى نتائج ايجابيه ربما تنجح في
تحقيق ما لم تحققه الوسائل الخشن على مدار
سنوات طويله بالنسبه لمصر الوضع اوضح او
اسهل بكثير اذا كانت مصر مستعده لعوده
العلاقات مع تركيا
اللي هي العلاقات كانت بينها وبين مصر
علاقات توكسيك او مسممه منذ
2013 بشكل مباشر
اكثر بكثير جدا من ايران واذا كانت مصر
سبق وطبعت مع عدوها التاريخي اسرائيل من
نحو اربعين عاما فلماذا لا تفعل نفس الشيء
مع ايران خصوصا ان البعد الخليجي لم يعد
قائما بعد ان مدت كل دول الخليج ربما
باستثناء البحرين والبحرين بالمناسبه
بتجري المفاوضات لتطبيع العلاقات مع ايران
وخارج منطقه الخليج العلاقات تظل متوتره
مع المغرب والمملكه الاردنيه وايضا هناك
محاولات ايرانيه لتحسين العلاقات مع
المملكتين فلماذا لا تسعى مصر لتحسين
العلاقات مع ايران كما فعلت دول الخليج
وكما تسعى دول اخرى لتحسين
العلاقات مع ايران على العموم عوده
العلاقات المصريه الايرانيه ستكون خطوه
مهمه جدا في اتجاه التهدئه التي تجري في
المنطقه لكن عوده العلاقات على اهميتها
ليست الا بدايه او خطوه واحده في مشوار
طويل جدا للتفاوض على كل القضايا الخلفيه
بين البلدين واثبات حسن النوايا ونجاح هذه
المفاوضات ونجاح التهدئه على المدى البعيد
سوف يكونوا مرتبطا ليس فقط بالملفات
الثنائيه المصريه الايرانيه ولكن بكثير من
الملفات الاخرى في دول المنطقه علاقات
ايران مع دول الخليج علاقات ايران مع
الولايات المتحده علاقات ايران مع
اسرائيل كثير من الملفات الملفات كلها
متشابكه لننتظر ونرى ويكون لنا ان شاء
الله حلقات اخرى مع هذا الملف بالغ
الاهميه اشكركم والى لقاء